[Music]
I'm not your baby but I'm hanging out
with my friends Ryan back maybe has
muscles for sure has muscles what did
you say wait what why only ready for
internet that's what you've done to her
hey Hanna you look great today and
during Mendoza who has grown muscles
since the beginning of today we're gonna
be talking about our deepest regrets and
to do that we're gonna use my favorite
sketch show the Kroll show which I
regret to think doesn't have as much
love regrets let's turn it off easy
right is there a lie that you feel like
you've told that maybe you regret maybe
don't regret yeah I once when I was
younger I stole a lemon magnet from my
nanny
I felt so bad about it
I just never getting back to her but she
never say anything just stolen I to this
day maybe that's it no I threw it away
today yeah I felt so bad you had to
purge the guilt
is there something you live it all the
time oh my weight how much I drink away
yeah well speaking about lies Jenny
slate lies very well in this next crow
clip yogurt water are you I think like a
lot of women really want to drink
something that's like medium thick try
I'm gonna try it if you don't mind like
I lie in meetings a lot it's true I like
the idea of just like sucking down one
of these little things like in this case
I really do hate water like heat it like
very exciting to be trying a new
beverage I love it it's delicious
thank you like water but I want that
sour teeth that like only yogurt can
bring so what can we do to help promote
your product on let's see oh I just had
an amazing idea what if we did an event
Liz it sorry you are a genius I love you
you're my best friend that's fine here's
what I'm thinking we should do cultured
water is like very cultured and like
what is the most cultured thing oh my
god
Englund London England so it's like a
theme party all about one and Anglin and
culture waters and then we can I was
like Adele perform we should have a del
perform I think it Adele might be a
little expensive so I could do it I
could actually just create the
performance I could do it I could
perform there's some yeah
such a funny choice whenever she has an
idea she snores so much I love did you
have life stuff you want to talk about
well the only life that I like to make
regularly I was thinking about it while
the clip was on is that I like always
tell people that like oh yeah we should
totally get lunch sometime yeah it's
like just it's not that I don't want to
get lunch with them it's just that it is
a lie because I know myself and I've
ever have free time ever it's going in
my PlayStation I know myself if I have
any free time at all I'm not leaving the
house I'm playing my playstation I'm in
the same boat I'm really hard I'm trying
to say no to more things but I ran into
someone on the street and he was like
dude we gotta play Catan sometime and we
were making full plans and like what we
were gonna do and who are we gonna
invite I'm like that's never gonna
happen
yeah ever yeah I don't like to leave my
apartment very much and yeah but it
wasn't relevant so yeah being a believe
have you ever had like a really
emotional goodbye I think the first time
I broke up with someone
furious yeah yeah this is a different
show now so the first time I ever broke
up with someone was freshman year of
college is like my first girlfriend from
high school and you guys tried to make
the leap we tried to make the leap we
lasted a month that's what it was and we
both were like oh great
Algie we went to different colleges too
so when we broke up we made it like a
big crying scene about it but like
onions I thought that's what we were
supposed to do but it's not really how I
felt like when you were like thank God
well yeah when we parted ways I was like
okay and then like I yeah literally that
night like I went upstairs to someone
else as a woman like okay Jordan talk
about sex I guess our bodies can I did
this your voice gets quieter your body
changes a little and you usually go this
is Jordan no but it's more like
delighted and there's like a face was up
started to dab and we just like started
to Devon this is my nightmare shot
shut it down but have you ever left a
job or been fired or quit to something
or is there anything new there I quit
yeah I like every other I know you're
putting just right now having lunch nice
well speaking about caring and emotional
goodbyes check out this next clip I
can't believe we're like packing up
publizity packing up publicity is really
hard because they hate packing it's time
for me to take a word of advice from
your bangs and grow was getting pregnant
to meet getting back we're going who can
never know like what will be told and
that is the story that like I will
discover when may path unfolds on it
extraordinary
[Music]
I'm going back to-- fella I'll see ya
now because like that's where my family
is and I'm gonna like call the Poconos
and like for once in my life I'm gonna
work hard you're gonna work don't you
lose out on me now what good we briefly
talked about bangs in that clip we're
gonna keep talking about banks have you
ever changed your look in a significant
way I got eggs I was actually thinking
about getting bangs again that's when I
know I'm like you need to go outside
I had a mohawk for 24 hours in college
because I thought that it would like
make me look like the other guys that
had Mohawks like I was on the rugby team
and they were all like much bigger than
me and they really that's cool and they
could pull it off and I looked like I
was going through something and
something was chemotherapy like it
really looked bad oh did that joke land
on the internet the chemo joke yeah yeah
maybe for the internet that'll land yeah
they love they love it someone's
watching and there's you know what you
guys need someone who takes risks and
who represents you and that's me because
I'm telling you that's what the case is
mine isn't soft yeah okay cool Wow I'm
rock-hard speaking of making bold moves
check out this next clip
hey Liz oh hey guys
I didn't even recognize me like are you
like hiding from like a paparazzi or
like I may as well soon be considering
considering like what bangs I got bangs
oh hey rats
I'm les I gotta be and I'm with our firm
is called publizity
[Music]
it's be some fine memes okay thanks you
should try it sometime it's like a
cleanse for like your fees for bangs
right congratulate hoes
we want is that a dig I am bangs now and
like you're being like shell itself like
the risk-taking that I've done by like
getting bangs like are you done like is
it over do you think it's a clone for me
to have my like best friend like be like
oh my god I like you got but it's like
no big deal like I mean it's like a big
deal honestly for me I don't know what
you're talking love your jar it's
amazing but like why would you show up
to work wearing salmon when you knew
that like honestly one of the other
executives with wearing salad I heard
that Salman is healthy for you but
apparently too much can make you sick I
wear Salman all on my own okay and I'm
swimming upstream and instead of seeing
another Salman I'm seeing a bear really
cuz I'm seeing a whale
Nakul is hot take away road that cliff
and sniff girl it's really hot so funny
you just want to know how much of that
was improvised you know it just feels so
yeah that Salman is like wine is so fun
have you ever accidentally given a
compliment that didn't come out right
a hundred percent that's everything I
say every single thing that I say is
misconstrued and then everyone makes me
feel like I'm an asshole my girlfriend
this was only a couple weeks ago she had
on a white shirt and like this like
brown jacket thing which I thought was
very cool and I said like hey you look
like you got like a really cool like
Indiana Jones thing going on and then
she changed her outfit yeah no girl is
going on being like a holding Indiana
Jones yes get that Harrison Ford today
you feel like you refuse great style
he's got great style they look like
shortstop a lot from that movie and I'm
like just that distorts shortstack
whatever that seems racist yeah dr. Joe
dr. Jones
we're Halloween I went as a fembot b-boy
like Oh Miss Piggy all right let's see
that next clip of the slack okay oh yeah
may help you I'm Denise
yeah my name is Liz I'm part of
publicity it's based off our names do
you know my aunt Elizabeth is okay you
guys can I hear okay hi sweetheart
I'm my aunt Elizabeth um nice Denise
and that's Cassandra you don't have to
pay attention to her okay so you came
here to see your aunt Lowell was enough
exactly my aunt Elizabeth invited me to
come and visit her and so I did and she
said me and her limousine from the
airport I feel like I should call my
parents and tell them that my aunt
Elizabeth didn't come after the law your
parents talked about your aunt Elizabeth
they said she's a piece of trash person
you're funny I like you you're funny
you're basically the largest woman I've
ever seen yo welcome what were you guys
like in middle school oh man so weird
uh-huh I don't know if I grew out of it
yet I was just a good boy I went to
school and went home and did my homework
and I was pretty happy about that
wait you're like the famous quote here
right is you were like I didn't realize
people hung out outside of school oh
that's true yeah I oh yeah people would
hang out outside of school but I didn't
really participate in that and really I
guess I didn't really know that they did
that's like blissfully wonderful really
good you're like ignorant to that I
think I just went home and I play with
my Legos and like I just had a good I
watch my TV shows oh my god our camera
guy just very softly went later I was
just doing message boards and like do
funny photo shops and talk to those
people online and I went on a Harry
Potter message board that was really fun
I actually really just push in message
boards and I got into Starcraft ones
that because of my parents that I could
get I could like play video games
because they wouldn't allow me to and I
was like you know I should be able to
make video games I've worked hard and
I've done my homework like after that I
should play video games and then I can
go to bed at ten o'clock Jordan does not
know he's a sad little boy
thank you for watching every damn day
leave us a comment about how great we
all are and turns out on Twitter at
extra damn day
[Music]